around 5 000 tourists a day used to
visit
the island of mauritius in all of april
this year there were just
58. covert travel restrictions have all
but destroyed the business model of
nations depending on tourism
it's a similar picture on the other side
of the continent on the
cape verde islands
the ocean and bays are picturesque on
the main island of santiago
cape ferd the archipelago it's part of
also attracts visitors with scenery
like this but things have changed since
the outbreak of the coronavirus pandemic
yeah before the pandemic many tourists
came here to tarafal
especially at this time of year but now
no one comes anymore
many of the archipelago's residents make
their living from holidaymakers
but the lack of tourists caused the
economy to crash
the pandemic revealed the policy of only
developing the tourism industry
may have been a mistake agriculture and
other economic sectors
have been neglected
we need to further strengthen the local
economy
agriculture fishing livestock domestic
tourism and so on
[Music]
because at the moment we depend almost
entirely on europe
if europe is blocked we're also blocked
automatically
many of the island's hotels are closed a
commercial sector that normally
generates a quarter of cape verde's
gross domestic product
now lies dormant many who work in
tourism have lost their jobs
hoteliers hope business will gradually
return this time
with guests from close by we've invested
a lot in domestic tourism
we've done promotions and everything
necessary for our citizens benefit
because now we have to invest in
ourselves and not just wait for the
europeans to come here
we also have to invest in what our
people want there are also people from
our country who want to come
so we offer them the best prices
things haven't been this slow for a long
time the locals now have the islands to
themselves
they can keep the fish they catch and
would usually sell to restaurants
but it's not enough for them to live on
let's get more on how the african
tourism sector is trying to cope with
the pandemic with elsia grand court
she is the regional director africa
department at the united nations world
tourism organization welcome to dw elsa
elsia
for the countries most dependent on
tourism what do they need to
do what do they need to happen to get
back on track
thank you very good afternoon um yes
uh for us the year 2020 has been
the worst year in the history of global
tourism
and as you say the crisis continues and
especially those countries
heavily dependent on tourism are really
experiencing a lot of difficulties
because the drop in tourism arrivals uh
what we have been
seeing in africa has even gone down to
minus
85 within this year
and definitely this translates into lots
of jobs
opportunities especially a lot of people
were also transacting in the informal
sector
but i think the realization also that
has come out of this
is that countries are looking at their
economic
model that they have moving away from
just
putting a lot of energy behind
developing the tourism sector
they're looking at diversifying the
economy they're looking at
other niche segments as well in order to
be able to attract
um visitors to their shores in the
documentary you just shared for example
cabo verde
they're looking at the pricing in terms
of
to be able to attract domestic tourism
in addition to looking at diversifying
the economy
okay do you see this sort of
diversifying on a large scale
or is this just in several economies
i believe that the tourism sector will
be
on the rebound uh countries need to
continue to consolidate the work that
has been done
in this sector but of course it begs one
to realize that indeed
we have to look at other sectors and to
look at the diversifying because
when your country depends heavily on
tourism and when the
source markets are no longer able to
travel you realize that it creates a big
gap
and uh now the focus has been on
reskilling
so that people can transfer to the other
industries
uh but of course uh the sector will be
on the rebound it will take
some time that's why uh our secretary
general has been pushing
for this con continuous collaboration
amongst
different stakeholders international
organizations and other un
agencies to look at restarting the
tourism sector
but of course uh taking into
consideration
all the the necessary protocols that we
have to adhere to in order to be able to
proceed with the restart of the sector
as your grant court of the united
nations world tourism organization thank
you